modern
vibrant and bustling albania's capital
torana
but behind this image there is an
industry that's worth billions
run by the country's criminal gangs
men always have control over women in
albania
this is where most of the uk's foreign
victims
of human trafficking are coming from an
abuse
which ends in forced labor and sexual
exploitation
on the streets of britain sometimes the
victims of trafficking
even fear that the police you know can
be corrupted
and the number is on the rise
flora a coastal city in the south of the
country
it's the location of one of just four
shelters in albania
that provides urgent help to victims of
trafficking
best jana not her real name was
unmarried and in her early twenties when
she fell pregnant
she told sky news how this brought shame
upon her family
and described how she was beaten by her
own mother and brother
embark they punched me in my womb so i
would lose my baby
it was very bad because at any moment i
could lose my baby
fleeing home she ended up in the hands
of one of albania's trafficking gangs in
italy she was forced to work as a
prostitute
for 18 months
yes it happened on the same day as soon
as we arrived at the house
within an hour he started to be
aggressive
they started locking me inside the house
and they threatened me and my baby
if i didn't do what they said or tried
to escape
she managed to get home and is now
reunited with her son in albania
this shelter is utterly vital in
ensuring the safety and security of the
victims they're helping inside but it's
a constant and difficult
challenge in the past traffickers have
found out where it is
and they've had to relocate to here
there's now 24-hour security
outside but many others don't get this
help
instead sold from gang to gang across
europe
and into the uk the number of potential
victims in britain
now runs into the thousands the uk's
national crime
agency has reported a 35 rise in
potential victims of trafficking
from 2016 to 17. the latest figures
show that last year more than 5 000
cases were reported
most foreign victims trafficked into the
uk
are from albania
we meet another victim now living in a
uk
city trafficked across europe by
albanian gangs and sold for sex
she's one of many women who were lured
by the promise
of a false relationship he did see me as
a
human being maybe just couple of first
months then
straight away i was his position
after two months i was bruised he waited
for me
for all the brews to go and then
he started bring other men
friends i don't know who what they are
i was just trapped in that house
and for most of them
we're just animals who try to please
themselves
and that's it because this case
potentially involves a minor in
harm this uk call center run by the
charity unseen
takes calls from trafficking victims who
are already here
so they call us sometimes from
situations of actual exploitation they
might be
um held in a residence and they feel as
if they can't leave or they feel trapped
and they might call us from a back room
and they don't want anyone else around
them to know they're on the phone and
they're trying to call very discreetly
the center gets around 30 calls a day
but it's likely there are many more
who are unable to pick up the phone
around half of reported victims of
trafficking in the uk
are being forced to work in the sex
industry the other half
face labor exploitation for example when
you get your car washed
if your car wash is is washing cars for
five pounds
but there are 20 to 30 members of staff
washing those cars
quick calculation clearly highlights
those individuals aren't getting minimum
wage
if you then have caravans at the back of
that car wash clearly those individuals
are potentially living
on site which means they can't leave
their area of work when you go to a nail
bar for example
if the person who is doing your nails
will not engage with
eye contact with you she can't speak
there's a person that's floating around
it's cash only and anytime that person
even dares to look at you straight away
the other person who's behind
clearly controlling that individual
intervenes clearly something's not right
this is the reality of modern day
slavery in britain
leaving thousands trapped among us
i'm afraid i don't want girls to go
through
not the thing that i have been through
but i don't want them
to go through even a single slab even a
single violent situation
or stressful situation because
i know what it means and i know what it
feels like more than
anyone else
but the victims will keep coming this is
a multi-billion pound industry
and one which is constantly evolving
in the late 90s criminal gangs would
traffic victims from this beach and
others along the coast to italy by speed
boat
it's less than 60 miles away the gangs
are still operational and active in this
city
but since the introduction of freedom of
movement into the rest of europe
their techniques and methods have had to
change
today young albanians are being targeted
by traffickers
online it's why these children are being
warned of the dangers of social media
and how gangs are using the platforms to
lure them away
from poor rural areas miners that
have been prey of the trafficking
through social media
they come from families with social
problems diverse parents
families that the violence is present
within the family and in order to to
save
from this situation they are prey of
false promises by the trafficker it's
vital work
more than 40 percent of victims
trafficked into the uk
are children
we're out in tirana with a charity which
goes on to the streets of the capital
to identify people at risk when you do
this in the daytime how many children
will you speak to on average
six or seven six or seven
[Music]
it doesn't take long before they're
[Music]
needed
[Music]
five years old three years old and one
years old
one euro more than one
it's young women and children like this
that are at risk of exploitation
albania is one of the poorest countries
in europe
the uk and u.s governments say that
and corruption in the judicial system
are factors
behind the country's continuing problem
with human trafficking
albanian organized crime groups are
certainly operating at the higher end of
sophistication
and they certainly exist in the uk as
they do in several other countries
within within western europe as well and
they are what we would call
poly criminals as well so not only are
they involved in
uh organized immigration crime and
trafficking but also
in drug smuggling firearms trafficking
and often
violent and violent and serious
organized crime
in fact just six people were jailed for
trafficking offences in albania last
year
and the government admits there is a
high level of corruption
we are under the process of the vetting
of police
so to have this pure triangle police
prosecution
and court because as you said sometimes
the victims of trafficking
even fear that the police you know can
be corrupted
and you know can uh exchange information
with with criminals
and their life will be of course in in
big risk
they can trust us they can trust
albanian institution
and we are here to help them
for victims like best jana it's a
message that comes
too late i would warn albanian girls
here and abroad that these guys may not
be what they seem
now i'm not afraid i'm stronger now and
i hope to live my life with my child
if you are a daughter your father
has control over you if you have a
brother
he still has control over you even if he
is younger than you
men always have control over women in
albania
a tougher approach may be on the way but
for now
trafficking is still widespread it is a
problem that by its very nature
is hidden and one which is shrouded in
allegations of corruption
from the bottom right to the very top
but the fact is that here in rural
albania hundreds of people are
leaving on the false promise of a better
life
you